makeup and heels high heels Define  femininity no no I'm not naturally  beautiful there is there is a standard  that they want to keep up they will  always want to represent their men it's  not it's not it's a sense of vanity the  same way there are Latin women dressed  in a certain way and they have a certain  standard of beauty and I do understand  actually when you look to certain  extremities of the world you do see  femininity in more in like higher levels  it's good for some people it's not good  for some people do you understand what I  mean because actually when we look at  these countries that have this sort of  thing realistically economically they  are suffering in different ways which  means that we need to look at the  society we have issues here but there's  also a certain way that we work that  helps us actually survive that's  corruption that's why things are kind of  messed up still